there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey everybody its episode 133
HP Lovecraft
yeah we're finally getting around to
doing this I mean you know if you guys
have watched the show for you know any
length of time at all um you know that
I'm a big fan of HP Lovecraft you know
here's my little shirt my she says a
necklace of it is that l ron Hubbard it
was a weird guy there was a lot of stuff
surrounding him weird stuff surrounded
him in his life and then after he died
his legend kind of lived on and became a
part of a the American horror scene
actually on a global scale
yeah I've been down in Central and South
America they know HP Lovecraft
[ __ ] yeah and it's funny because he's
one of the very few authors that I can
think of who's I mean it's very obvious
where the ideas for his stories came
from from his like particular neuroses
yeah um it seems like that it's really
the most one-to-one kind of relationship
that I've ever seen between an author
and his work you know what I mean but in
a way it's like yes he was a weirdo and
yes he had a lot of problems he had a
lot of prejudices and stuff like that
but if he hadn't been that way I don't
think his fiction would have turned out
the way it turned out and I don't think
we necessarily would remember him today
he was a man of his time and a strange
man of his time yeah even then he was
considered very eccentric and he was a
shy guy not not well developed in terms
of personality and social skills but he
got better as he went along yeah
unfortunately he didn't live very he
didn't live early but he did get yeah he
did get better as he got a little bit
older its he was a late bloomer I guess
yes some people kind of painted him as
some kind of a racist type of deal but
no he was just kind of a shy guy that's
all
think from a British point of view even
though he was American he was he was
that he was an Anglophile in America and
he wrote all of his stuff based upon
kinda like his idea of what he thought
of an Englishman would think of
something that's kind of how he wrote it
oh and he definitely was a racist a lot
of the [ __ ] he wrote because it wasn't
just his fiction it was like he wrote
like a hundred thousand letters during
his lifetime he goes through it for
other authors you know a lot of the [ __ ]
comes out in [ __ ] that he wrote yes it
was a very racist time also
but even friends of his like were marked
up on it so it was like yeah he didn't
like he didn't like any kind of outsider
it was it was bad even for the time yeah
I guess I guess you could say it
probably was it was it was remarked upon
at the time yeah so he thought anybody
who wasn't an Anglophile or English -
even Ian even non English white people
he looked at him sideways yeah pretty
much everybody
he thought that Anglos Anglo Americans
were the height of civilization if you
weren't like that then you were kind of
a barbarian yeah or subhuman yeah use
that too but it read well and horror
especially for the time well like I said
even though like I said yes his it's
eclectic [ __ ] that he's talking about
yeah I mean like his attitudes in
nowadays like reading it with a modern
sensibility you can be like oh he's
talking about you know black people are
you saying my news or whatever which
clearly he was or Puerto Ricans but yeah
yeah or Russians
yeah yeah Russians either um you know
but in a way I think that kind of made
his fiction work because I mean
everything sounds sinister well yeah
because that was the way he saw the
world and I think if he hadn't seen the
world that way yeah no she talked about
wooden beds Gary it what he wouldn't
have written what he wrote like I'm sure
he wasn't a fun dude to hang out with he
was a shiny nerd Hin yeah I'm glad the
house much and he was just scared
everything yeah fantastic
he wasn't much of a ladies man either
I'll tell you I mean later on I think he
got one girlfriend
and married one married well yeah but
this was this guy was like in the 50s
they would have called this dude a
square
yeah a square super uptight and nerdy
yeah round round real tight nowadays
honestly I'd I think he would be I don't
like to psychoanalyze people from afar
as nothing they've been dead autism
spectrum yeah yeah I would say
assburgers probably yeah yeah he was
super like that like that that was
pinging all my alarm but like oh like
the way he talked and stuff like that he
was very intelligent and um you know
like I said later on kind of got out you
know into the world remember and I
remember hearing somebody that had read
something that some know I remember
somebody was saying that they had read
some of his friends material and the
friend said that he had these weird
views of non angle Americans you know
and he was talking about all the
immigration that was happened from
Eastern Europe and there was Porto
Ricans and black people and stuff and
that he was real uptight about it but he
also saw in certain kids certain
occasion when you actually met that
person he kind of felt him out a little
bit it took me a while to relax around
I'm heroes that they were okay well that
one eventually and actually he had the
self-awareness to say and some of his
later letters that actually getting out
in meeting people different people right
changed it um kind of changed him
somewhat so he did actually get like I
said he didn't live he'll he died when
he was 46 which is how old I am right
now but um you know it did lessen a lot
when he was younger he seemed to have
all this weird adolescent like superior
yeah type of attitude yeah like you know
he was very edge lordy like he came off
like it's not really he can't it's like
I should be you know British aristocrat
I didn't have to work and even though he
was broke yeah he was broke no no they
had I thought they had lost their money
and they still had it when he was a kid
okay but by the time you know he was
drowning
you know yeah by the time he was growing
up like his grandfather was with all the
money it was but yeah so I think he
wanted his whole entire life to have
this you know to have the kind of life
of a British aristocrat where you can
just lay around in your mansion yeah
write poetry for the hell of it give
free money and yeah and not have to do
anything like not have to work not have
to mix with like brown people or
anything anything even Irish people yeah
or even Irish Pete yeah I said they
didn't have to be brown it could be
white just yeah if they was Laing or
something like that he would get all he
would get all up sometimes the label of
racist I think in modern terms I don't
think it applies he was weirder than
that he was generally misanthrope me
yeah he was weirder than that anyway and
the stuff he was writing we're gonna get
into it later after we get into her a
little a little love cuz we had to our
shout outs and stuff the stuff he was
right and really was out of fashion even
during the time that he was right yeah
his it was he was very archaic like yeah
he kind of sounded like like writers of
the eighteen hundreds and I think he was
emulating them he was yeah he wished he
had been born back then right
I think he didn't really like he liked
in the modern era from a scientific
progress stamp standpoint but in general
he thought he was kind of one of those
guys that like look back at some earlier
time period like it was more genteel you
know type of thing and he read a lot of
you know 18th century authors Alexander
Pope and all that kind of stuff and he
wanted to be like that yeah you want he
wanted to be like the 18th century
gentleman yeah he didn't quite he didn't
quite have the the writing skills though
if you ask me and and he would try to
show off his vocabulary a lot and when
he did that he'd used the same words a
lot over and over he did yeah weird
Eldridge a lot yeah he could rake in he
could he could make a creepy ambience
but what was funny about his
roars is that it wasn't a lot of action
in him they were mood pieces they're
more like mo yes generally which he I
think he gotta got that from PO now I'm
kind of interested I mean obviously
there's no way of knowing this because
he died in news 46 but um if you read
like I have this book here I have this
book here the HP Lovecraft II complete
fiction and it has all of his fiction
stories like in chronological order and
if you read them in chronological order
an interesting thing emerges is that
very early on like his work was very
gothic at a very Potok flavor
later on after he discovered Lord
Dunsany
he was a big admirer of he started the
whole they call it the dream cycle where
he did like the Cthulhu Mythos where he
wanted to kind of build a mythos of
these Elder Gods and alien gods and
stuff like that and then he kind of went
off into a direction which I think had
he lived he might have turned into and
I'm not saying he's not a brilliant
writer but his style is very wooden it's
kind of wooden in static slightly you
have to know what you're getting into
you but he was getting less of that like
as he was getting older he was kind of
shedding a lot of that he was getting a
lot more he would actually describe
things like in a specific way where you
could picture it I think he started to
actually kind of right action scenes
yeah certain things with the shadow over
Innsmouth for sure yeah dad had an
action scene that a lot of people
commented on he was getting better yeah
what he was great at though was setting
a mood and creating nowadays what you
would call a universe yeah all right
they really have that back then in
impact in those days but he was making a
universe in fact there was a cult of
people that started to follow his work
the thought that he was somehow
channeling a cult truth and cults were
forming around this guy yeah you know
you want to meet him he didn't want to
meet him his fans you said it said his
fans horrible he was scared to death up
minded alive glad to have
no memory some of them he had a couple
of them that were tracking him down he'd
meet him easily one talked yeah and the
thing about that you know what we know
today is the Cthulhu Mythos wasn't
really I mean it originated with him but
the whole you know codification of it
that didn't come till later that was
August Derleth that was like his other
like other writers of his circle sort of
did that whole Elder Gods older guys and
that like made sort of a pantheon yeah
what HP Lovecraft did was he just kind
of wanted this he didn't even call it
that Cthulhu Mythos I wasn't called that
until after he died he called it yog
Sothoth Ori like as to be to be funny
yeah but he encouraged a fanfiction yeah
people wrote stuff that was like right
off you liked that well because he had
taken ideas from earlier writers too so
he liked and you know when he got into
that circle and other people started
liking his ideas like I said when he
came up with you know Cthulhu and all
the other gods I think in the
Necronomicon and whatnot he just wanted
that to be like the background of his
stories that would just hint it like a
larger yeah universe he didn't have like
a thing that said you know this God you
know gave birth to this guy blah blah
blah they have that now but that
happened after he died like other
writers that took his thing and ran with
it I think what made him cutting edge of
the time is that the writers that came
before him whenever they tell a horror
story they always kind of gave it from a
Christian point of view yeah I mean even
even Dracula yummy yeah well it's very
good versus evil
good versus yeah not Lovecraft Lovecraft
was like they're gods but they hate you
or they're indifferent or they don't
give a [ __ ] about you you're right and
that was a scarier concept back in those
days I think that really freaked people
out that's when my God won't save me but
now your God has made up the real God or
one of the real gods it's watching you
that hates you is this big invisible
thing with black eyes and it's got huge
wings you know it's that kind that kind
of stuff yeah
and it's gonna come back and you're
gonna pay that guess I think that hadn't
really been done before and I think
that's kind of why HP Lovecraft still
resonates so much today and why his work
just exploded like later on because he
was kind of won he was for sure ahead of
his
he was kind of like the Godfather of
modern horror because he was the first
one to kind of posit this in different
universe hostile universe there were no
God no no one would save you coulda
prayed anything yeah um if it even
noticed you it was just like you were a
bug it would just stay it was almost
kind of like a religious horror yeah
we're in a universe of evil gods or
indifferent gods and aliens from other
planets and aliens who worship other
gods and that your gods are false gods
yeah and then there's these cults
working in the shadows that are actually
worshiping a real God and it's evil and
it's common yeah you know it's pretty it
happens this far-out idea for his time
it definitely was yeah I said and you
know it's a shame that he didn't get
more fame for it in his lifetime but
like I said I think that people maybe
just weren't ready for it I mean you did
get published I think was rejected
basically well if some people liked it
yeah it did get published a lot but it
got published in like pulp magazines
yeah a small readership mainstream
America wouldn't have accepted that no
other writers do Doggett yeah but there
you want to hear that they wanted good
versus evil and somehow Jesus involved
in here you know I mean God will save
you from Dracula that's that's that's
what they were used to yeah they didn't
want anything inverted and turned upside
down like that yeah to where yeah you're
fighting Dracula but guess what his gods
the real God yeah like I said I
definitely don't think people were ready
for this I mean it's kind of a shame
because I feel like how do you lived
longer he might have started to see you
know how influential he might end up
being I think if he had lived until the
50s I think the 50s I think people would
have got into it I feel like it in the
50s people were probably ready for that
[ __ ] maybe I worried that maybe well
they're probably well people were
getting a lot more into the into sci-fi
yeah you know what I'm imagining that
[ __ ] fallen in a lot got fallen in
with Ed Wood and Ed Wood just driving
him into the ground
yeah Edward and Bella Gus it would have
been horrible
you'd have Bella out there rolling
around little squids and yeah oh hi
plates together
on fire like UFOs like old ones coming
out and as sad as that would be I kind
of want to say that that's probably what
would have happened to him I think he
would have ended up with hanging out
anywhere dad would just burning it up
you know I mean just use enough
Lovecraft's name and Lovecraft sitting
there staring at him just crazy with Ed
Wood and that damn angora sweater drag
yeah I mean Lovecraft would have just we
were like on your xbox we were looking
there's a game on there is it called
what's it called Lovecraft versus Tesla
right or - yeah Call of Cthulhu is out
yeah but I was like man that sounds like
the raddest game ever you have to
download that but it's like it's it's
not as cool as I thought that wasn't
actually game it's cool-looking but it's
not as cool-looking as I thought it
would be and it's just kind of like a
shooter you type a game there's nothing
like down on it yeah and I was just kind
of like huh I was kind of disappointed I
wish it well you know cause like the the
artwork for it we're saying I'm like
Tesla versus Lovecraft yeah I have to
have that yeah but then I was kind of
like hmm well yeah I don't know I mean I
think I think um I think Lovecraft
probably would have gotten to be a
better writer had Helia his later stuff
is much better than his er I still don't
know if that would have made it into the
mainstream though I just maybe yeah
maybe I'm not I don't really could say I
can't really see him fitting in well
with Hollywood circles especially its
kind of seen a phobic as he was yeah he
didn't like Jewish people yeah
and he wasn't real good at
self-promotion no he was a lonely guy
big nerd kind of you know yeah kind of a
hermit kind of a hermit and kind of uh
he got better later like I said but he's
waged as the way he described they're
talking about Asperger's syndrome I
think he thought it was beneath him to
to make Ronny yeah that and to try to
sell his own work it seemed to make him
really uncomfortable he was just like a
really really really really insecure and
kind of immature people saying I was
kind of
behind thing not very flexible and
immature yeah that's definitely how he
comes across it's why we say when they
label him a racist I kind of like I
can't take his racism seriously he
didn't know anybody I know that as he
said his friends said well once you got
out to the kind of meet people he he
laxed up it was like oh you're not a
name oh yeah yeah you are a human being
okay but yeah all right so let's do a
couple little shout outs and then we'll
kind of get deeper into the whole thing
if you didn't see our last movie review
it was poltergeist the tobe Hooper slash
Steven Spielberg blockbuster from 1982
so go check that out also I put some
more shirts up on the Zazzle store
finally at long last I got the running
with kukulcan shirt up there yeah I got
a bulletproof wolf shirt skinwalker
ranch one and I have a very delightful
charming wandering whim one it's super
cute it looks like a little postcard so
check those out I haven't seen that one
yet yeah I made that one the other day
also um and I think I mentioned this on
the last couple episodes but I have a
game crafter sort the game crafter it
has to be the game crafter calm called
giallo games and I think I showed you
guys crimson drop on a crystal palette
before and also I showed you Kirstin
names of nightmares before but here is a
new one this is my so far my magnum opus
yeah this game looks pretty cool yeah
this one is called the three Sorrows let
me get it up here for the cams big yeah
it's very very big we're gonna get a
shirt like that that's gonna be yeah I'm
gonna make this uninsured though so it's
got all kinds of cool patterns in they
don't know if the light can pick it up
yeah well I'm all about the texture yeah
this one is actually like if you've ever
played mystery mansion where you kind of
build the board as you go like you have
little rooms and little hex is that yeah
there goes some guns there's another
room
yeah you just had it you build the
mansion as you play yes and it's kind of
based on you know
levana and our ladies of saara which of
course was the basis of Suspiria that
has like these three witches or these
three sorrows and they're trying to suck
away all your happiness you're trying to
kill them you try to like collect
weapons to kill real pretty little cards
once shoma card yeah a little-little min
that you move their little wooden are
some cards it just comes with a standard
52-card deck right here and it's got
cards like you did no I'm showing okay
you know and there's like they have
little weapon cards like blue which ball
yeah the quality is very good this is
which is our color-coded so you have to
get like the weapons like there's
something like Rowan berry yeah like
stuff like that so you know some that
Matt boy the board pieces yeah there
were laser-cut there real thick almost
was like wood yeah is like a pretty cool
but we have these these are the yeah
they're still this is yeah this is what
it comes it's like when you get it you
just these little rooms right here show
to back and then that's the back there
there little hexagon shapes and you just
pop them out and like I said as the game
norm the artwork how cool yeah yeah it's
hard to see like I said it's all
textured and stuff cuz I love doing
texture on the back and stuff especially
on black but yeah so it's like all these
little rooms in a mansion and you build
it as you go like I said kind of like
mystery mansion you know a little bit
simpler than that prob about 45 50 bucks
somewhere because the components for
that were kind of expensive it's
expensive gaming to make and like the
box is big in every but this box is
pretty and it's like something you can
put on your shelf next are you're
blessed I'm trying to make them like
yeah pretty enough that like people you
can just play it yeah
but yeah so check those out go to the
game crafter and search for geology so I
have three up right now for sale and I'm
gonna be working on another one probably
you know when I get all this other [ __ ]
done that I have to do so it might be
like next year but you know we'll see
how that goes
also I've been rear according the audio
for the unseen hand by the time this
show goes up it might be out I think the
faceless villain one irie recorded the
audio for that that should be out by
that should be up by the time this show
comes out and like I said I'm almost
done recording the unseen hand audio
like re-recording it with the better
microphone so I just have like two more
sections I have to do and then I have to
edit it and it's about four or five days
yeah so and then I'll get it put up in
the nest
it takes ten days yeah so hopefully by
the time the show goes out days you know
or soon after this show goes up the
unseen hands should have been
re-recorded yeah because this this will
good this show will go up probably what
three weeks so it'll probably up it
might be close to being up when this
yeah watch this is going up the first
week of March yeah
I think calendar yeah okay well then a
few days that means that one that unseen
hand will probably be up the new version
yeah it probably well alright so let's
talk a little bit again about HP
Lovecraft yeah now very famously he was
born in 1890 in Providence Rhode Island
a city which he had a great deal of
affection for and really didn't want to
leave until later on in his life as I
said he came from a fairly affluent
family or one that had been fairly
affluent his grandfather was named
Whipple which I kind of loved now he had
been like a big industrialist and stuff
like that but by the time that HP
Lovecraft was born you know the finances
had dwindled somewhat I mean they were
still wealthy they still had a really
nice house and Providence but you know
it wasn't the way it was so I think that
that was something that sort of informed
HP Lovecraft's life subsequently is that
he only felt like fallen aristocracy
it's not a thing like he thought that
he deserved a better life like he should
have grown up in this year fancy house
and with no work you know he didn't have
to work yeah he definitely did because I
mean you know what was changing though
even back in those days in the United
States yeah because there's a big waves
of immigration coming from from Europe
yeah at that time and you know just
business models were changing you just
couldn't live the way you could live it
back in the eighteen hundreds when the
time ago and even Poe didn't live like
the way he thought Poe lived what was a
bump yeah wasn't any mine hoe was broke
dick is yeah yeah I had this kind of had
this image that he should have been
living up in a nice mansion writing some
writing some [ __ ] like he's Lord Byron
or something yeah you know travel in the
world writing books you know yeah like I
said just like not working a real job
you know it's kind of like laying around
but yeah so I feel like that was kind of
where that was coming from now his
family was very old I mean the Lovecraft
family had I think him over on the
[ __ ] Mayflower I think so you know
they'd been there for you know many
generations so he kind of like thought
of England as his you know motherland or
whatever so later on when he's a younger
kid his dad is sent to a mental hospital
after some undisclosed he was like on
some kind of business trip or something
like that and like all the people that
were with him said he kind of had some
kind of flip out and they said that he'd
been acting weird like before that but
like this is like super yeah but uh what
they ended up finding out later on after
he died in the mental hospital was that
he had had syphilis and I was making him
crazy um I don't know if Lovecraft knew
that it was syphilis I'm sure he did um
he might have known
later on we his mother treated in my
theory I think that he knew it was
syphilis I think his mother bagged on
him about it yeah and the interesting
thing is that Lovecraft's mom Susie
didn't have syphilis which maybe means
that who's going around yeah that her
and the husband didn't and and that ad
was actually something that that loved
cry
have to said about his mom that she was
very he called it touch-me-not yeah like
she wasn't super physically affectionate
she wasn't you know what I mean
and her and Lovecraft's relationship was
kind of weird um it seemed like you know
a lot of sources have said that she said
to a neighbor or a friend of hers that
oh he doesn't go out of the house cuz
his face is so hideous yeah and like he
doesn't want people looking at him and
thought he was ugly yeah and all this
other kind of stuff which he wasn't
especially not as a kid he looked like a
total normal I mean he was a little
weird looking when he got older but when
he was a kid he looked like a total
normal kid I had this theory that what
happened was is that she hooked up with
this guy you know lovegrass dad yeah and
it was kind of a loveless marriage yeah
and got knocked up yeah and had little
HP okay and then the DHB then hit HP's
dad started to show symptoms of syphilis
so I think what happened is mom shut him
off you know yeah and I think it was
kind of a an inch he was a sexless
relationship yeah and then she was kind
of regretful of having that son yeah you
know I mean because like a philandering
dad type of deal and maybe she wasn't
really quite sure much about disease
maybe she thought that in some weird way
HP might have some kind of a disease
yeah that might that that that checks
out if the dad had it maybe he's got it
yeah and they owes maybe she had it yes
some some I never heard of her having
done no she did go mental later and they
did put her in a mental hospital and
they yeah probably the problem is that
the diagnosis at the time as it was with
pretty much every woman ever was
hysteria so what the [ __ ] does that mean
we don't know she had it too she might
have but like I said most or some but
sources I read said that she didn't have
it and that's why they thought how would
they know I'd heard that there were some
treatments that they had they could kind
of keep it in remission a little bit
they used weird mercury treatments that
kind of kept it in check but eventually
to catch up with you yeah and it would
make
get real wouldn't you know a lizard-like
very you know very unemotional yeah so
kind of mechanical looking so that you
look like a living robot when you had it
when in remission for a long time
[ __ ] she had it yeah so like I said
his mom was not super physically
affectionate but she was like super like
uber overprotective of him and you know
kind of took him everywhere I was like
fussed over I'm gonna shine at it - I'm
gonna say she had it - but what she may
be she well I'm sure you know better
than anybody how could she not well like
you said they might not have had sex
until like until after he'd already got
it just like he might have got it cuz
like I said he was like some kind of
traveling salesman or something so he
was probably like knocking down chicks
all over the place I don't know what he
looked on I'm just saying he probably
had it she prided oh I think they're
just covering for her reputation well I
don't know but so anyway so the kid so
Suzie and the kid Howard Phillips they
go and live with you know in the family
house there with the maternal
grandparents which is Whipple Phillips
and his wife Roby that was HP's
grandparents and also two of his mom's
sisters Lilian and Inez they lived in
this really big nice house now HP was
kind of a roll sickly kid very nervous
disposition you didn't have to send your
kid to school back then it wasn't the
law so he kind of went off and on he
didn't really seem to like it that all
that much he didn't like math he didn't
understand it it gave him migraines he
said um you know what I mean he wasn't a
dummy like he could read and stuff like
that but he really did not like school
he didn't like being around other people
so he was just kind of in and out and
finally he never graduated high school
or anything like that
now while he was in this house evidently
his grandfather was like a big influence
on him while he was alive because he had
like this big library of you know all
this classic literature and stuff and
Lovecraft was super into that so you
know his grandfather would read to him
or
Lovecraft would go up into the attic and
like read all the books and stuff he got
super into science like he was really
into astronomy and chemistry and stuff
like that although chemistry he wanted
to be more into it but like I said he
couldn't do the math and it kind of
frustrated him so he just said God [ __ ]
that so you know what I mean
so it got kind of like that now his
grandmother died in 1896 and then after
that like this sort of Paul fell over
the household it was kind of like you
know his mom and aunts would go around
dressed in mourning like these B black
dresses on and he was only about five or
six at the time and he said it kind of
freaked him out so he started having
nightmares and nightmare night terrors
around this time of these things that he
called night-gaunts which were kind of
like these black like figure like shadow
people I guess type of thing or you know
the kind of flying demonic whatnots
people are they call it sleep paralysis
he might have yet it did sound kind of
like that and I wonder if it was because
of you know after his grandmother dying
and then like all of this grief like
taking over the household you know it's
all these women like flitting through
the house and black dresses and everyone
bummed out and everything all the time
so that I mean he was a very sensitive
child so I feel like that probably
affected him because the first thing
that I thought of when he started
talking about the night-gaunts when he
was a kid I was like that sounds like
and I think that walking around in the
black dresses yeah and I think this is
pre electricity I think this is during
uh wasn't this during the time of gas
lamps imagine how even even when they
did have electricity - how creepy those
New England houses were at night oh yeah
because the light bulbs are really low
wattage even if they had electricity
yeah so they always had this weird you
know if you see those old Victorian
houses you know I've you know lived in
Boston you know we're in the Somerville
Medford area and for a while I lived in
a I guess I guess I lived in -
Victorians they're [ __ ] creepy yeah
they're creepy and imagine that they're
real creepy back then when there wasn't
any electricity and you were a little
kid people have been dying yeah when
that have been you wouldn't that been
word and like I said you know no
television no radio really I don't think
there's a writ because what year was
this would have been this would've been
well 1896 his grandmother died okay
yes or no radio yeah and he was about
six years old then yes it was a very you
know as a kid you would have felt like
very isolated in it very like a
different kind of world you know yeah
not the modern world you know today
well yeah where everything is loud and
flashlights all too active video back
then it got dark and she's like ooh and
the whole city was kind of quiet yeah so
um by all accounts like I said even
though he was in and out of school and
didn't really care about it all that
much he was super into reading super
into science and stuff like that and he
was a pretty
he was pretty you know ahead of the
curve like you know he was writing poems
and he was like seven the first things
that he got into doing were writing he
was super into like Greek and Roman
mythology Homer's Odyssey all that kind
of stuff so he would read those and he
would do like his own little versions of
them um he also came to atheism pretty
young because and this is funny because
this is exactly how I got into atheism
from Greek and Roman mythology because
one day when I was little and I was
reading it and it suddenly occurred to
me you know a long time ago people
thought this was real yeah that's like
they think yeah they think Christianity
is real so I made the connection and he
seems to have made the same connection
at a very young age so I'm like I said
he specifically called himself an
atheist later on so you know and it was
the same thing with Santa Claus like
they told him Santa Claus wasn't real he
was like oh god let's not be really
there like he figured that [ __ ] out
pretty little okay so um let me see what
else are we doing
okay so around 1900 his grandfather
Whipple I just like saying that Whipple
van Buuren Phillips that was his name
that's white as [ __ ] I know isn't it
that's like the white I wish I had a
name that white I'm gonna start calling
you whip all call me Whipple van van
Buren
damn it would only be whiter if the last
name was hyphenated yeah yeah he looks
like a wet ball too like if you see
pictures of him so by the time 1900
rolls around like his business has
started to go down like I said you know
before that
they'd been you know fairly affluent you
know in town we're very prominent family
but so the business starts going
downhill the servants had to be let go
so they'd have servants prior to this
solo craft got used to having maids and
[ __ ] around they didn't have that was
real common though yeah so it was a job
didn't have appliances back then yeah II
had to hire people to come and do
laundry so they don't do laundry you
just fill the damn washing machine
well yeah they're really doing well I'm
not just saying do you laundry I'm in
general I do everything but um alright
so that went on the decline went on for
like four years and then Whipple's
business just completely failed and he
ended up dying of a stroke just a couple
of months later so he left what was you
know remaining of his estate to Suzy
hp's mother but it wasn't a huge amount
and today every time you say HP yeah
well that's what I love that's why I
laughed when you said HP because I said
leave HP sauce yeah that's like that's
like that's like limey a one sauce it is
yeah it's very it's kind of similar yeah
sweeter yeah it's got my head in a long
time they have it Publix I should get
some yeah we have British groceries that
our public is right around the corner
right here in Central Florida yeah
because there's a lot of British people
living in Orlando that's why yeah
well have Jamaican stuff to they have
everything on the lawn down yeah but I'm
just saying well when I was growing up
it was really hard to get British stuff
you had to go to like I had to go to
like this little tea room like in
Daytona Beach and they had like some
British groceries like the regular
grocery stores didn't have them but when
I moved to Tampa I was super excited
because regular groceries had a little
questionnaire but I bought in that same
aisle I think it's Caribbean stuff it
was called Malta Malta yeah Malta that
suit is pretty good it's like a little
dumpy vault now violet it says a little
bottle of like black malt drink yeah
yeah man it was good with some ice cream
blended it up with ice cream man it's
really good I could it looks like malted
milk I didn't like a malted milkshake I
couldn't yeah
live it down that's some [ __ ] that the
Caribbeans think that it's high-calorie
tell you that isn't it funny that like
I'm and I remember this because like I
said you know I'm 46 years old so I grew
up in the 70s I remember in the 70s
pretty much the only quote/unquote
foreign food you can get in grocery
stores was like those Latroy chow mein
yeah thanks like in a box and that what
about some exotic [ __ ] what about back
in the seventies in if I could Pizza kit
yeah where you had like a you had it was
Italian yeah a can of tomato sauce in it
and like a package of flour and you made
a cross that remember that and and and
then and then and then a pack of
Parmesan cheese and there was no way to
execute that thing to make it anything
like a pizza they didn't have taste buds
and as an offshoot to that I was really
excited that I get to share this like
you guys I got this like on Amazon like
a from a like thrift store like a book
store I saw it online I'm like I gotta
have this [ __ ] look it's called the
amazing macro pudding plan this woman
found these [ __ ] Weight Watchers diet
cards like from the 1970s and they're
horrifying
and worse a resident these like recipes
are just like who the [ __ ] would eat
this [ __ ] and it's like I'm I'm
wondering if it was Weight Watchers
because it's like this [ __ ] was so
revolting that like you'd lose weight as
you couldn't eat it or you throw it back
out because it for real looks atrocious
American food is [ __ ] crazy I know
what the [ __ ] man what the hell 70 I was
there and I don't even know why but um
but yeah so it's a really funny book she
write and she writes like a little you
know funny little uh
you know comments about it like on the
side of the thing like she found these
like in her grandma's attic or something
like I got it I got a recipe book and
there's a Betty Crocker Betty Crocker's
recipe book from the early for early 50s
late 40s yeah it's excellent cuz it
teaches you how to make mayonnaise it
teaches you how to make just like
components alright yeah but one of the
funny things was is like the
Warren section in the foreign section it
had a recipe for spaghetti I know like I
said that was exotic [ __ ] back then and
then in it and then it tells you in this
instruction says there's this very
exotic spice that you have to get to
make this taste right it's something
called oregano that if you can find
oregano yeah it didn't have a regular in
the United States in the late 40s or the
50s
everything was made of jello or came in
yeah but yeah that's what I was thinking
I was like it's it's just funny now cuz
you can go into any grocery store and
get pretty good anything I get Thai food
Indian food you know like bagel whole
aisle is [ __ ] not back then there was a
whole explanation of what oregano was
that's hysterical if any of you other
old people out there remember that [ __ ]
isn't that funny it's like oh yeah
that's funny and then in the sauce how
to make the debate that the pizza so
that the tomato sauce no mention of
basil no mention of parsley no mention
of I think it did mention garlic no
mention of any kind of onion powder or
anything is I get too crazy it would
have been the most bland spaghetti sauce
in the [ __ ] world like I said nobody
had taste buds back then I can't no I
don't think they had the components
maybe it was all the smoking didn't have
the components I don't think maybe
everybody just smoked so much that their
taste buds a mold people when we were
kids as old people go into the
smorgasbord yeah that was like real food
yeah she was bland as [ __ ] you and I
mean and then everything else was oh
that's ooh too spicy black pepper oh
[ __ ] no the smorgasbord just boiled
stuff little bit salt on it maybe that's
what I mean it's like fur for many years
like for many years I hated pork chops
and I hated pretty much all vegetables
because they were boiled to [ __ ] well
this [ __ ] all slimy yeah those import
chops because they were back then they
were afraid of trichinosis yeah so they
would take the pork chop and they would
just garnish it it was like you could
bang it against the plate it was that
[ __ ] tough it was funny is that there
are still people here and then I see
that will overcook pork
yeah nosis has been annihilated yeah
it's gone gone you can eat like
you can eat raw pork brother yeah you
can eat rare pork is it but yeah it was
a different time back then that's that
was from our grandparents era but that
kinda I'm fascinated by that kind of
crap so I like I love all that like
mid-century menu that blog where she
makes like these recipes from back then
we got to give back to HP so anyways so
after a Whipple died you know the
family's finances kind of charged
started to take a nosedive and they had
to move out of the family home now this
upset HP a lot I mean this is the only
homey D'Souza's an entire world really I
mean he'd never really been anywhere he
didn't go to school all that much or
anything like that so they had to moved
like to this dinky as little duplex him
and his mom and his aunt's and around
this time like he said in letters and he
told friends later on that he said he
just didn't want to live anymore like he
contemplated suicide and all this other
stuff because there's you know his whole
like I said his entire world had been
upended and it's like his whole
conception of himself as this British
aristocrat living in this really nice
house with this genteel existence you
know now they don't servants anymore now
they moved to this and the house they
moved to wasn't super shitty it was just
way less nice than where they had been
you know what I mean yeah so let's see
um you know as I said kind of in and out
of school he started like some little
magazines like about science about
astronomy and stuff like that he also
started writing fiction around this time
and some of his first stories were once
there was one called
alchemists there's one called beast in
the cave these were very very Poe
inspired he was super into Edgar Allan
Poe and he was super into like I said
stuff from the 18th century yeah you
when you read and which you read Poe
then you read some Lovecraft you can see
where he's borrowing from Poe yeah
especially in his early stuff yeah you
know you can see this is almost like Poe
fan fiction in a way yeah and he
recognized yeah I mean he said that
that's not this that's not you know too
slight Lovecraft he actually had a
pretty good taste yeah yeah popo's good
yeah so he wanted to sound like Poe he
wanted Lovecraft wanted to sound more
important than he was he wanted to be
like a classic writer from another era
yeah and I think it worked
yeah it's a word just this kind of like
it was just kind of this conflation of
all these different like influences you
had it's like if it had been someone
else maybe it wouldn't have worked but
the way he went about it
he's weird as he was yeah I think if he
had just been a normal dude but I don't
know if you have been able to polish it
work because it worked because he was
kind of a weird guy
yeah and he was very much I think he
felt like an alien in his own time
yeah I mean he felt like he was out of
time he should have been born 200 years
ago he thought the world was too modern
yeah back in those days
honestly when he started corresponding
with other writers of doing like a
maternal ism and stuff he would like
complain about them using slang or
modern American isms cuz he said oh you
get that from the immigrants and that's
Mattern and we should we don't talk like
that right and all this other stuff so
he was very into very very proper
British English and if you didn't use
that from another era though - yeah and
then yeah and even then it was you know
very behind the times like there weren't
any really other contemporary writers
writing in that particular style I mean
most of them wrote in a more modern
style that you know that would sound
more modern to us but he did not want to
do that he so he was very like harkening
back to like a much earlier era and like
I said he was very aware that that's
what he was yeah and it's kind of weird
when you're reading these books the way
he's setting the tone of the story using
that vocabulary yeah and then the
subject matter is so weird you know that
all kinds of come together
comes together it's just it just sounds
[ __ ] weird I mean somebody in the
late 1700s early 1800s talking about
aliens and brain transplants and gods
that have come through other dimensional
doors you know man you just don't expect
that subject matter coming at you in
that form
maybe that's what makes it work as the
juxtaposition yeah that's why I was
really modern as it makes it sound true
or even postmodern yeah object matter
but in this very archaic yeah language
yeah it makes it it makes it sound truly
like it really happened like you're
reading a some kind of a classic
historical document or yeah or some kind
of religious document yeah
gives him some gravitas yeah and he's
talking about aliens yeah and they're
not good aliens yeah you know I think
yeah that and that's actually a good
point I think that might be some of the
appeal of his yeah and when he talks
about these aliens he doesn't really
include any damn technology aliens have
flew through space because they could
sleep for millions of years you know
just sounds plausible yeah that's how
the that's how the damn blob got here
just fell in an asteroid you know as a
biological organism yeah as an alien and
when you see the blob for the first time
when I saw it the first time as a kid
you know I'm back in the 70s it was old
movie back then that movies look [ __ ]
plausible yeah at the ground and you
grab it and this stuff gone on yes
dissolved you I always thought that that
was a very modern yeah horror movie yeah
the whole flying saucer thing and guys
carrying around a magic with just above
the head and it never never really it
was cool but you could tell that it was
something that a person made up to me
yeah no well yeah you know it was just a
dude in a constant yeah but there's
something the idea that something just
fell from the sky and a meteor yeah like
a type of contagion yeah but still kind
of like creature yeah a creature that
gobbled you up you absorbed you yeah I
got bigger basically a space amoeba yeah
that's what it was yeah and that's kind
of stuff you know Lovecraft's aliens
were kind of like that but they were
intelligent bodies yeah I could handle
technology once they got here yeah they
could even you know cut a human being
apart and examine them yeah that was a
really good that was one of his best
books that was a in the mountains of mad
mad No
evidently they're just trying to be
they've been trying to make that it well
Guillermo del Toro has famously because
he loves Lovecraft a lot he's a big fan
he has been trying to get that movie
made forever yeah although I was
watching earlier today I was watching a
channel and he was talking about the guy
on their camera what his name was but he
was talking about the best Lovecraftian
movies like of the last few years not
necessarily based directly on stories
but in that same kind of you know same
kind of thing and he actually
recommended one that's called a rune and
over here called black mountainside that
came out in 2014 and it's actually
loosely based on at the mountains of
madness actually the first um the movie
that John Carpenter's The Thing was
based on yeah that was based on at the
mountains of madness also and also it
was who goes there
yeah yeah but yeah the but that is a
very loved raft the creature from the
thing as described in the movie that you
know other thing sounds a lot a lot like
a shag off yeah which is a creature from
an alien creature that's mentioned in
the mountains of madness yeah and it was
a slave race of alien creatures that
some other aliens had enslaved and that
they lost their civilization because
that slit that slavery is revolted
against them yeah because in it a habit
absorbed one of the old ones which was
the name of the aliens or what they call
absorbed one of them and got and figured
out how to make a brain yeah cuz the
Shagal that was just could just copy
whatever it absorbed it didn't really
have a sophisticated brain eventually it
got had its hands on a sophisticated
brain and it spread that knowledge to
all the rest of them so they got
intelligent yeah that's how they
overthrew their masters and it looked
just like that thing from the think kind
of yeah just describe his mouths and
tentacles and eyes and it could just
change into whatever it needed to and
that's why so many people you know cite
the thing is being like one of the best
look crafty and so even though it's not
directly you know based on a Lovecraft
story it is very love crafty and in tone
and theme
but yeah I so I just heard today about
this movie called Black mountainside
from 2014 which is supposedly loosely
based on at the mountains of madness
there's also one called Banshee chapter
which came out of 2013 which I think is
loosely based on from beyond so but it's
this it's the same plot as the stuart
gordon from beyond from 1986 which we
did a review on we gotta see those them
but yeah so yeah I wrote them down cuz I
want to see him so I don't know I didn't
see either one of them on shudder but I
don't they might be on Netflix I don't
know but if not we can check out but
anyway it's time to take a break
um let me see where we at yeah probably
we're about an hour all right so we're
gonna take a little bit of a break right
now and then when we come back we will
talk some more about HP Lovecraft the
faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest unsolved murders of the 20th
century volume 2 includes cases spanning
the years from 1960 through 1979
featuring such infamous crimes as the
triple homicide at Lake Bodom the family
Massacre known as the good heart murders
the serial killings of the Zodiac Bible
John Jack the stripper and the freeway
phantom the slaughter of dozens of women
and girls along the highway of tears and
the Texas killing fields and the
mysterious death of suspected spy the is
doll woman along with dozens of other
fascinating and horrifying accounts by
it now from Amazon in print Kindle or
audiobook format
look at this gremlin baby here
he figured out how to get in my office
and underneath my computer what's up
baby werewolf hmm I'm gonna mess up whoo
look at it lit up we're back talking
about HP sauce
[Laughter]
he's all right he can write a book yeah
his way
yeah his writing was the best part about
him like I said I mean you know so what
well I was just saying you know he was a
strange guy who first time I mean people
that knew him liked him
but he was weird you know well and a lot
of people that he had these lifelong
friendships with a lot of it was you
know through letters yeah he didn't meet
a lot didn't meet them right yeah like
he did later on like I said like he
actually went as far as Key West later
on I was like amazed when I saw a
picture of him and a couple other people
in Key West Florida eventually he
eventually gets a girlfriend well yeah
like I said yeah and I think she was
Jewish girl to one Gigi was yeah yeah
CeCe
she would surprise him see ya prize
himself it's just sitting in his room
talking about telling how bad he was
[ __ ] Russian so I can do is [ __ ]
that and the other thing he didn't know
anything he did meet what he's like oh
well he's peeing all right he's picking
this up from what he's hearing yeah you
know what do you and then he's imagining
yeah you know but yeah so okay at this
stage like I said they move into this
smaller house his mom and his uncle
tried to kind of get the business back
going but they had like a really bad
setback and lost even more of their
money so you know like I said it's kind
of going downhill HP and his mom are
kind of reclusive at this point like his
mom kind of goes around she goes to like
women's suffrage meetings and stuff like
that but a
he kind of like walks up into the street
like was Rinku you know collar up and
like won't look at anybody in the eyes
and he's you know that kind of [ __ ] yeah
I said they're all walking around doing
that I was gonna say before too that
when he was in high school like like I
said off and on some of the other
students said that he had perceptible
like tics like he would like jump up and
all that kind of stuffs they think he
had some kind of like what they what
they would call now like minor Coria
where it's just kind of like tics sort
of thing so he might have had some they
think that he had some physical ailments
as well as mental ones cuz he was for
sure had some depression and had some
other things going on too but they think
that he might have had some physical
ailments as well and like I said he died
very young I've cancer maybe he had
syphilis also yeah or May or maybe it
was complications from you know her
having it or I you know I don't know her
from so yeah so there was all this kind
of stuff now like I said he had his own
kind of little magazines they were
usually about astronomy and he wrote for
those he had one called the conservative
that other writers came and wrote for
the first poem he actually had a poem
published in 1912 in the newspaper and
it was called Providence in 2000ad and
it was all about how all those poor
proper English people were gonna get
subsumed by the hoards of immigrants
like yeah that was the first thing that
he got published that so
alright so around 1911 like he starts
writing letters to the editors like in
different like pulp magazines and stuff
like that and he kind of got he kind of
got in regular correspondence with a lot
of the other writers that were writing
for this kind of stuff even if he
criticized their [ __ ] sometimes the
writers would be like well he's [ __ ]
on my work but he's so articulate and he
seems really intelligent so sometimes he
would like you know strike up
friendships with them like through
letters and things of that nature so he
had all that kind of stuff he had like
little little feuds like nowadays would
be like a youtube [ __ ] fight like in
the comment section or something like
that but back then you had to do it the
old-school way anyway to letters and
then you had to wait and then like a
couple months later you'd be like I'm
gonna talk
[ __ ] and it's like comes out in the
magazine you had to practice penmanship
you had to buy good stationery I'm gonna
[ __ ] him up this time all right and then
you have to write it he's like writing
all the insults he's like pencil first
and then like trace it back yeah that's
that's exactly right and it's a I'll
write some that he actually wrote about
another writers characters where he said
his characters exhibit the delicate
passions and emotions proper to Negroes
and anthropoid Apes
that's what he said yeah yeah so yeah so
that was something that HP Lovecraft
doesn't like I said yeah but um so also
maybe they made him mad but down the
subway how they write about you so
what's funny is that on some of these
documentaries about HP Lovecraft like
some is like biggest fans that are black
guys that are reading him you know that
yeah they read you know well like I said
they forgive the guy who was he was up
his time and he I do he's he's a
sheltered guy yeah a very sheltered guy
he's not real worldly I generally put
those people in those days said he was
not worldly know pretty good I think he
was a virgin until he got married like
pletely
well yeah 30s yeah so it wasn't much of
a ladies man no he was one he was a one
lady man and then then it lasts all that
long but yeah yeah she was Jewish and he
was gone he want to be all racist until
the snatch was involved I guess so he's
like well well you're the thing he's
kind of cute you know yeah yeah actually
she was a beautiful woman and she was a
very accomplished woman she was a
businesswoman she basically supported
his broke ass yeah
cuz she had a hat shop like she had
other businesses and traveled all over
getting jobs yeah she took in places and
stuff yeah and it's like she was like
super sweet to him yeah she took him
places she made him move out of
Providence it's like and she was sent
him money she offered to buy him a house
when he moved back to Providence for
[ __ ] sake
yeah
Oh No good for you girl he must have
rationalized it somehow but his friends
said he was backing off all day yes but
I think his thing was more like if you
were one of the unfavored races oh yes
this kind of word that was kind of
wording he was yes that's why I said it
like yeah if you were one of those but
you acted like a British aristocrat like
you talked like that naughty and
everything like that
then then that was cool he just didn't
like people being unassimilated or
speaking languages other than English or
doing things that British people
wouldn't do he didn't like people that
were practical yeah if you spoke in a
practical means that you yeah he didn't
like slang he didn't like anything new
anything mano really and I can I
guarantee you he didn't have much of a
sense of humor he really did not know
like I think I've seen maybe one picture
of him sort of smiling yeah but in most
pictures he just not right now to dream
that [ __ ] off the wall yeah you out of
tees didn't probably I would have to on
the other like I said I'm a big
Lovecraft fan like I love although I'm
proud of got him laughing you might have
and then just I love all this on again
we should have got him drunk that been
really really funny
although honestly he might have just
been one of those angry driver just
shame on you sir that just started going
on a racist tirade or anything like that
I feel like it would have been no fun at
all push him in an uber he would have
called me a little Irish sandwich oh my
god I would pay money to see that better
time machine so we can do the [ __ ] we
know Irish savage back to Mississippi
you see to slapped you with a glove and
stuff yeah but yeah so anyway so all of
this stuff that he's writing back and
forth whose letters to the editors and
like you know bitching about other
people's writing and whatnot
actually did get him attention from like
various editors and various other
magazines and stuff now at this time
period there was sort of a little
renaissance of amateur journalism not
like you know it's nowadays everybody's
a [ __ ] journalist it's like a buddy's
got a blog or [ __ ] YouTube channel or
whatever just like we do but um you know
I mean where they talk about whatnot but
that was kind of a big thing then
so people were starting to publish like
little zine zand you know writing all
that kind of stuff so he kind of got
into that circle and this is something
that really kind of opened up his
horizons a little bit because he started
like corresponding with all these people
that you know if even if they didn't
share his like weirdo worldview because
you know some of them were Jewish some
of them were gay you know stuff like
that
everything existed back then and I'm
sure that probably his friends were like
I'm just not gonna tell him any of that
you know what I mean
but um but it was something but they all
had like the same like kind of literary
interests and they were all into amateur
journalism everything so he kind of got
in with that I said she hadn't even an
imagined a gay person I bet he was very
like uh sex-negative yeah I bet you if
you had told him about that he probably
would have said Donna's not true know
what I can't be making that you made
that up
yeah I bet you he wouldn't even believe
that probably no it couldn't be try this
guy evidently like Eve as much as he was
into the sciences and like astronomy and
stuff like apparently in his
grandfather's library he was reading
like an Anatomy book and when he came
across like the section about
reproduction he was just like oh like no
way he was just like totally grossed out
by it now later on his wife Sonya um you
know I don't know if she was just trying
to like protect his ego or something
like that but later on she said you know
I think he was a virgin before that but
she's like he was totally fine totally
adequate in that department but that she
had to initiate everything yeah which
makes sense because he probably he was
geared yeah he just seemed like kind of
scared of women who's scared yeah he was
scared of everybody
honestly well he's made horror man yeah
it seemed like a sad way to live like I
said in a way I know this is terrible
like but in a way
I'm glad he was like that because you
know his fiction was so good and has
been so influential yeah and it's like
if he'd been a normal dude you know I
don't think it would have come out the
same no one we wouldn't even be talking
about him if he was a normal dude he
wouldn't have been obsessing and over
these little things and it wouldn't have
created just a weird-ass stories that he
came up with yeah exactly cuz you know
he was he would kind of make a big deal
out of some trivial [ __ ] even in the
book but he would make it sound pretty
[ __ ] weird yeah I mean you know just
little details about stuff yeah I
definitely feel like yeah like I said
nothing life scared him a lot yeah yeah
and in him thinking about it yeah it's
just I don't know it's just so funny to
me like I said he's he seems like and
and that might even be a slight against
people with autism because like people
with autism you know some depending on
how severe it is um can usually have a
fairly normal life but he kind of did
later but it's he really really had some
problems I think he was in the spectrum
I think he was in the autism spectrum
yeah well they probably say it was
probably something like very mild
Asperger's that's what I would say yeah
cuz nobody's nobody complained about him
being a know-it-all per se although
maybe it manifested in him know-it-all
ISM manifested in his English diction
yeah man they said that he would correct
you if you you know I mean didn't want
you using slang around him yeah maybe
then well that was one thing that he
complained about in other people's
writing what I'm saying meet me thought
it was improper that may be a symptom of
very mild he was a great ass burger
maybe we'll see well he didn't like the
idea well like I said you know what he
didn't want it he didn't want anything
was languaging
yeah he didn't he didn't like the idea
of the English language as morphing or
moving changing no it had to be like it
because we're picking up words from
those other languages and this and that
yeah yeah he seemed very much like that
like I said loosened up a little bit
later but it took a long time for that
to happen yeah a lot of this [ __ ] we're
talking about that he's doing I mean
he's still kind of a kid when he's doing
a lot of this stuff he's about 20s yeah
you know your [ __ ] in your 20s
basically everybody is pretty much
that's just goes yeah your [ __ ]
ashiness doesn't do that you get a
little bit older then you get the [ __ ]
kicked out of you Utah and back then
people people develop more slowly they
didn't have a mass media no internet no
TV even the new radio durin during parts
of this times so transmission
information pretty slow yeah if you
didn't know a lot of people you weren't
getting information right it's yeah
that's the thing so some of his earlier
earliest stories like I said you know
we're very polite you got you know ones
like the tomb and stuff um but also
around this period he also wrote Dagon
and yeah and that's we actually did a
movie retrospective on Stuart Gordon's
version of Dagon which actually I really
like I think it's one of the best
although the movie is more an adaptation
of shadow over Innsmouth yeah then the
story of Dagon they just call it a [ __ ]
they just called it Dagon it has like
some elements of that and everything
like that
Spanish movie in English but it's
awesome when you see it yeah like I said
it really has that Lovecraftian flavor
to it
yeah but Dagon I think is kind of like
his first story in what would later be
termed the Cthulhu Mythos it's like I
don't you know it was just this kind of
thing where it was the first story where
he was starting to come up with this
nascent idea of these other gods and
like I said a lot of the idea of coming
up with this pantheon of alternate gods
came directly from Lord Dunsany
who was another writer who he admired
quite a lot now Lord Dunsany style was
also very kind of like purple and
over-the-top very like the Bible really
his stories were not horrid they were
more fantasy but he kind of had these
other realms like fairy tale type things
and it almost like Tolkien sort of but
they had their own pantheon of gods and
Lovecraft loved that idea and so that's
where like after he started reading
dunsany a lot he said you know I want to
have this whole pantheon of these
alternate
gods you know to kind of be as the
background like of a lot of his stories
and I think Dagon is kind of the first
one that you see like the first hints of
that because prior to that like I said
it's posed his stories were very polite
very gothic you know just a lot like the
ones at the time yeah and I always like
the kind of directions that HP would go
in they were either like a fish god yeah
an octopus God some kind of Egyptian
type god along those lines you know
pretty pretty cool yeah I was there's a
there's a really good documentary it's
quite well known it's called fear of the
unknown about HP Lovecraft you know
Guillermo del Toro's Don they're talking
Neil Gaiman John Carpenter and John
Carpenter actually says at one point in
there he's like man HP Lovecraft US
really like hated fish well we would
think about it back in those days there
wasn't a lot of weird [ __ ] you could see
yeah if you went to a restaurant or a
market maybe one of the weirdest things
you'd ever [ __ ] seen be an octopus or
a lobster selling it in the market yeah
you're looking at that go on what the
[ __ ] that doesn't look like anything
you'd see on land yeah so maybe maybe
we're looking at seafood freaked him out
yeah you're like man that's possible
look at that thing you know like I see
an enemy you know or I have seen like
some people pointing out that like he he
had so many like tentacled and creatures
like that because it was like a vagina
thing which I guess some of them
probably were written into some of them
were vaginal looking but I don't think
all of them were I think he was just
freaked out by [ __ ] that was in the
ocean cuz it was like funny looking at
alien looking yeah and that's the most
alien thing ladies that you could come
across you know that you could actually
look at I remember being a little kid
going down to the beach and seeing
things like seein enemies yeah man
that's weird yeah it is weird they do
look like alien creatures yeah like a
totally different yeah well these little
tentacles and fate is that a face coming
out of the ground you know see an enemy
thing you know
so you know if you're an uptight dude
like HP you see that you go yeah that's
evil personified whatever that thing is
whatever it does that's bad it's just
funny that like Cthulhu has become such
a such a cultural touch touchstone it's
like you can get [ __ ] slippers that
look like Italy get a little Funko pop
of like a cute look what yourself and in
HP shoes you know late 1800s Early 1900
you can go to a market you could go to
the beach you know you lived he lived in
their Beach area near Providence you
know you can he could get to the beach
and you see stuff like that right yeah
and it's pretty common you see in
tentacled seein enemies and you might
see a squid or you might see an octopus
for sale you know or a lobster or
something a crab well if you can see
that what else is in there look at how
big that oh [ __ ] is yeah so if you keep
going out there what else is there well
that scares me too yeah I mean and
honestly some of the [ __ ] that one of
the things that scared me that most as a
kid is I had a book about fishes and it
had like a artwork of like you know
here's shallow fishes and here's like
kind of yeah okay and then they showed
like the deep ones like the one like the
ones with the teeth and the [ __ ]
white thing hanging off their heads like
the bioluminescence and stuff and that
freaked me the [ __ ] out well they didn't
know that back then you know there's
peace day you know you just had to
assume that well this is the stuff
that's up close to the beach and it look
how ugly this [ __ ] is yeah it must get
worse as you go yeah it just gets just
gets worse bigger bigger and worse and
worse and worse as you go out there some
of that shit's intelligent you know
something that [ __ ] out there's even
more intelligent than a human yeah you
know that you might surmise that yeah
and that's a pretty reasonable thing to
surmise if you sure know what else was
going on down there you know they hadn't
explored the seafloor back then and you
know they know about giant squid yeah
you know all right so can say that yeah
maybe there's something out there with
human intelligence living underneath
there and in his in a city I think
octopuses are smarter
some people I've met but okay so around
1919 HP HP's mom Suzy starts showing
symptoms of a mental breakdown like she
starts seeing [ __ ] and like acting
really weird and everything like that
they didn't really know what was the
matter with her at first well no she
wasn't that old
okay um but they actually ended up
putting her in the same mental asylum
that his dad had died in right and you
know obviously like I said it was 1919
she's a woman so obviously hysteria
because she had that uterus problem cuz
uterus is make you crazy because that'd
just be crazy disease so yeah so they
slapped her in the mental asylum as well
and then she ended up dying in there
actually they were doing an operation on
her gall bladder and they [ __ ] it up
and she died a few days after that cuz I
guess she got an infection or something
like that so after his mother died you
know lovecraft again you was thinking
about suicide and all this other kind of
stuff but as the time went on like later
on that year after he had kind of gotten
over it a little bit he sort of started
to get a little more outgoing maybe like
who was paying the bills um they had an
inheritance from Whipple was the house
paid for um that I'm not sure
like I said they had moved into a much
smaller house and two of hp's aunt's
lived there as well okay oh there was
money coming into that yeah and but he
didn't I mean he didn't make a lot he
made money by doing like little editing
jobs he did some ghost writing he did he
ghostwrote [ __ ] for [ __ ] Houdini
which I didn't know actually him and
Houdini were gonna write a book about
superstition like a nonfiction book and
he had started working on it they found
some of it like another Jewish guy and
but Houdini died like before they could
finish it so I never got finished but
Houdini was a big fan so I actually
didn't know that until I was researching
this show
something that doesn't get mentioned a
lot there you go HP Jews were helping me
out doesn't mean it's like that just
trying to help you weren't out for day
we're now to get you bro
yeah yeah worrying too much so yeah so
he kind of you know like I said after
his mother died he goes into kind of
look a little self-imposed isolation but
then he comes out and he kind of starts
getting around a little bit more he
actually leaves the city whoo he went to
Boston because Lord Dunsany who is he
was a big fan of was like giving a talk
there or whatever so he went and then he
started going to like little amateur
writer conventions where he wrote other
writers of his age particularly Frank
Belknap long who actually became one of
his closest friends pretty much for his
entire life
um so and I think it was actually at one
of these a little like amateur
journalists or writers conventions that
he met Sonja Greene who would later
become his wife now she was a few years
older than him she had been married
before so and she lived in Brooklyn so
she was actually a much more worldly
black I said she owned a business she
was fairly successful shouldn't rich or
anything like that she was you know she
was thinking it was a woman for him it
really was and she seemed to have she
understood what she was dealing with I
think I mean I saw on the on the fear of
the unknown documentary about him they
had Caitlyn Kiernan on there talking uh
you know she's obviously a big fan of
his and she was saying that she thought
maybe Sonja green was probably something
like a saint because she she basically I
mean HP Lovecraft did seemed to
genuinely like fall in love with her but
she really seemed to take him under her
wing and just like you know I'm gonna
expand your worldview I'm gonna
introduce you to sex I'm gonna yeah you
know I'm gonna take you go you're laid
yeah I'm gonna take care of you I mean I
said to show you what these really are
yeah she made money and she supported
him I mean pretty much because he made
some money doing ghost writing and
editing and stuff but not much cheap
rails I saw that there was something
there you know there was some talent
there that that you know I mean Mike
come to follow yeah and she was a writer
as well and he the cool thing about him
was that he actually encouraged her
writing as well like sometimes like you
know they'd be you know out and about
doing something and like
get an idea for a story and he's like
what you know why don't you write that
and she would write it so some of her
stories were published as well so they
actually got married the ants did not
like that I don't know if it was because
she was Jewish or they thought there was
something else wrong with her I don't
know but um the ants didn't didn't like
it but whatever probably with the times
it was probably more like she was
considered to be kind of a loose woman
or a used-up type of woman because she
was because she was divorced divorced
that might have been what it was that
yeah that right that they did seem to be
very like right waspy Protestant like
uptight kind of like oh you're divorced
owes goods
hmm even though like I said see pictures
of her there's pictures of Sonja green
she's a beautiful woman I didn't think
she had kids were the first out of
initiative no I don't think she had any
kids but like I said she was a few years
older than a lot like hugely older but
she was several years older well she
needs somebody he needed somebody older
than him don't [ __ ] tell me what to
do to them yeah and like I said you know
it's kind of a shame I don't want to
call him a bum he wasn't a bum um it's
kind of handicapped yeah it's like he
did work a lot like he wrote a lot he
wrote like over the course of his life
they think he wrote like a hundred
thousand even they're socially
handicapped yeah he's not he wasn't the
kind of guy that could promote himself
he wasn't the kind of guy that could
like mix with fans and build a huge fan
base yeah he wasn't that kind of guy he
wasn't the kind of guy that could
shuffle around knock on doors and get
jobs yeah
you need to be need an agent yeah you
know our manager because like I said you
know he he wrote voluminously
but one he seemed to have a thing about
how like he like he would write
sometimes and either because he thought
it sucked or because he thought it was
beneath him to make money off he seemed
to have like a weird thing like that
like he wouldn't even or like if a story
got rejected once like he wouldn't send
it anywhere else he'd be like oh well
that's the end of that one you know what
I mean he would do stuff like that like
self-defeating he was very self
defeating it seemed like um and if you
read some of his letters he's trying to
try to make a business out of something
and you're yourself defeated like that
you're gonna fail and the thing about it
is that you know I you know I'm a
creative person I'm a writer
all writers are super super
their own work it's like you know I've
read I've written something and then
read it back and it's like that sucks
donkey balls I can't let anybody else
read that and stuff but you can't I mean
his [ __ ] the way he saw his own work he
just thought it was terrible he always
thought it was terrible and I don't know
if he ever realized like how good it was
maybe he did later on but so I don't
know if it was so much that because
there came a time when he would only I
mean when weird tales came along you
know the very famous pulp magazine that
pretty much got his start he that was
the only place he would submit to
because they had already you know they
wrote it publish to publish some of his
stories and he had a relationship with
them I mean they they rejected some of
his story especially when another editor
came around later on but that seemed
like the only one that was like
acceptable like he wouldn't there were
other pulp magazines he could have sent
to but he never did and even he worried
a little bit too much because he did
yeah his writing was developing yeah his
early stories tended to be short they
also tend to be very kind of wordy yeah
a whole lot would happen to them and in
the very end something would kind of
resolve itself it was kind of like that
pattern there wasn't anything really
like a novel until towards towards the
end I mean he's really starting to write
novels a real book yeah but then he died
yeah it wasn't his it seemed like it
novels weren't his preferred medium
which I understand that it was
Challenger do that yeah he did write one
case of Charles Dexter Ward but even
then he specifically had an editor ago
hey you got any novels um and he did it
was done yeah but he never typed it it
was written he wrote everything by hand
but he never typed it to submit it he's
like no I don't have nothing like that
yeah
and it's a good book it's good and I
don't know why like it's very very
self-defeating to have a manager that
wrote all our that read all his stuff
and stayed on top of him yeah to
represent him yes
which like I said Sonya seemed like she
did a little bit but she also she had a
business you know
she didn't really love time I wasn't a
Salesman and people write people that
create stuff have a hard time selling it
it's true yes I do
yeah it feels like bragging it's much
easier for me to sell her stuff that her
to sell first yeah I mean I'm not as bad
as long as it's not like I'm bragging
yeah yeah it because that's something
that I haven't maybe love her after had
this - I don't know but we're you know I
don't I don't like it seems like it's
unseemly to like to talk dude about your
own stuff and I think he had a little
bit of that too like it was you know it
was not classy
you know what I mean it made you seem
desperate yeah that's kind of I don't
know I've always seen it like that so I
don't like to it also makes me wonder
how much advice lovecraft would have
taken from a woman even if even her
probably is he needed a bro somebody
that read his [ __ ] you know I mean and
could screw him into action he had like
a whole circle I mean there's a whole
circle of people even while he was alive
for the Lovecraft circle okay and they
wrote stories like using his mythos and
stuff like that so obviously he had to
know that there was some talent yeah
behind it because other people were
liked it yeah other writers were
probably saying hey man can I use that
concept right you know so obviously you
wouldn't do that if you thought it
sucked well I just you know I don't
remember all the little details it's
been a while since I've you know read up
on him but just you know this is all off
top of my head from what I remember he
was just starting to stretch his legs
mm-hmm and I was under the impression
that he was just getting ready to start
doing his greatest [ __ ] then he died I
kind of felt how I felt was going
because if you read like I said in that
particular book that I have that has all
his fiction in chronological order you
can really see his developers already
finding his own style his own voice
because a lot of his early stuff like I
said it's very its derivative is what it
is not in a bad way there's still good
stories but you can tell that his style
was very very much influenced by and
it's funny because you know later on
later writers like Ramsay Campbell and
stuff like that
Ramsay Campbell in particular started
out writing pretty much love stat
Lovecraft pastiche until he you know
went on when he was young very young and
then later on went on and developed his
own
I'm actually a big fan of Ramsay
Campbell as well I mean he writes a lot
in the Lovecraft mythos you know he's a
more recent writer but okay so Sonja
like I said she lived in New York City
and she made HP moved moved to New York
City which was crazy like I said because
he was a Providence guy so they moved to
her apartment in Brooklyn he did not
like it
like I said entirely to me too many
immigrants for his liking and he was
just miserable the whole time he was
there there's a quote from HP Lovecraft
that come to mind I can paraphrase it
Lovecraft said it was racial prejudice
was nature's mechanism for protecting
what evolution has created to remain
separate that was the kind of [ __ ] that
he would say because it does seem like a
lot of his horror is based around humans
and Monsanto quote an inter reading and
yeah an evolution and that dark forces
do this [ __ ] yes I mean innit you know
like I said and that's one of the racial
prejudices meant to keep us yes you can
read his stuff now you know and knowing
the time period knowing the kind of guy
he was but he's one you can't really
forget about it entirely because it
informed so much of his theme so many of
his themes were racial genetic lineage
like he was super super into value man
or alien her bloodlines demigods were
gods and humans coming together evil
gods and humans coming together yes into
all that yeah so that's what I mean so
in some ways that's why you can't just
say oh well you can just read stuff
apart from his racism or apart from the
way he was or his beliefs because it's
really tied in with yeah it was all
because you could see it come out
I mean sometimes
yes sometimes blatantly it's sometimes
it's really blatant and I was gonna say
that shortly after he moved to New York
and then they moved to another apartment
Sonya actually lost her hat shop that
she owned there and she went and got
another job but it was in Cleveland so
she went and moved to Cleveland like
temporarily and lovecraft stayed in New
York City but he had to move to a
smaller apartment and he moved to an
apartment like in Red Hook which at the
time was like a really big immigrant
area and he flipped the [ __ ] out and he
wrote like a story called the horror at
Red Hook and that's one of the most
racist [ __ ] things I've ever read
it's like it's horrifying that he read
another one called he that was like that
was very similar then because he just
[ __ ] hated it he hated it yeah so
yeah so if you read horror Red Hook that
was he was living there at the time and
that's how he felt about it so it's
pretty special
okay so yeah um so at this stage like I
said now Sonya and HP were they were
still married at this point but she was
like moving around to find work so she
was going to actually move to Cincinnati
because she got another job opportunity
there and she wanted HP to come with her
but he's like no way that is like too
far
that's the Midwest that's like too far
from the north it's like as long as he
was staying in the Northeast it seemed
like he was alright he didn't like New
York City but he was willing to go there
but Midwest he's like no I'm not going
there yeah we keep talking bout this
racism you know and he's not talking
about black people well he's talking
about the other year well he is that
that's that one that's just one one
because it was African was everybody
everybody that wasn't Britain even
Germans even [ __ ] on German yeah yeah
yeah everything that wasn't like British
aristocrat these [ __ ] Russians yeah
oh my god these Italians anybody so just
it was even other white people yeah
we're people we would consider white
nowadays yes maybe people you wouldn't
even notice as being like as being dead
as being a net different ethnic group
we've neery who says he'd noticed that
[ __ ] yeah that's what I mean it was like
he was like uber racist yeah cuz he's
like only British people were good yeah
or only this is what I'm saying that I
don't
what you said I don't I don't think I
classify that as racism just too damn
weird yeah he hated everybody that
wasn't him that wasn't him and it didn't
really have even do with color so like I
said I really didn't I don't really take
a [ __ ] seriously because it it's just
just - it's just bizarre it is just
bizarre like I said it's it's almost
kind of like he's faking it but but he's
not I guess he was no he was area how
could you be that weirded out by oh my
god the Dutch oh oh [ __ ] oh the [ __ ]
Dutch oh so you know okay I just
pictured yeah a t-shirt with a little
windmill on it it says oh my god like
nobody's gonna understand that right
whatsoever it was it's not really it's
not really racism when it's
equal-opportunity [ __ ] freak out yeah
I mean he freaked out on everybody yeah
like I said is this some kind of a weird
day ahead yeah so alright so in priority
been hilarious actually I think I think
if I were there if I were there in a
time machine witnessing the ship I
probably would find it [ __ ] hilarious
it brought it think about it it's sad
but funny at this is yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
Italians oh [ __ ] you know I mean I grew
up in the south like my grandparents not
my grandmother's so much but my
grandfather for sure if it's like super
super racist and um so I kind of grew up
around then my dad kind of his - but
it's funny to me because I thought it
was strange even when I was a little kid
and like I would read it when I was
little and I would read these books that
were written in like the 40s or 50s and
like there was one book in particular
yeah I would read stuff by you know like
starring Sally J Friedman's herself and
stuff like that about a Jewish girl and
you know there'd be these books where
people would be like talking about who
that
Irish name is and I'm like people really
know what an Irish is what the [ __ ] is
that about I was like I just thought
that was it was an alien concept
well Irish Irish Pete you know you know
now you know I'm of Irish descent Irish
in German Sallah by Irish people were
that were the black people of the of the
white people yeah basically you thought
of that you thought of him that way too
he would have yeah he would have hated
your Irish ass yeah and baggy slave days
adhere between an Irishman and a black
person is that a black person was worth
money and iris pet yeah they took the
took that charming the British tips
Irish women his slaves and [ __ ] you know
yeah yeah but but yeah so I I don't know
I just always thought that was weird he
when I was get you would want to even
though I grew up in kind of a racist
environment like in a kind of a racist
family like I I don't know I was just
thought it was really weird like people
talking about like oh the Irish and the
Italians I'm like what's the [ __ ]
difference who cares
so anyway so Lovecraft had been living
in New York and hating life he lost like
40 pounds that's how stressed out this
[ __ ] was and Sonia was like look
I have work in Cincinnati I can't come
back are you gonna come here or what and
he's like no I can't do that so he's
like I'm going back to Providence so he
goes back to Providence his ances help
him out and Sonia like I said she even
offered this chick man she has like the
heart of gold she has a heart of gold
she says I will buy you a house in
Providence but the answer like now we
can't let that we can't let a woman like
biomass he can't support a wife that's
like not cool bras like you know what I
mean it's like it wasn't proper um you
know I mean because they don't like her
so so that whole plan was scuttled but
he did move back to Providence and when
he moved back there this is kind of when
he started writing a lot of his like
real iconic stuff you know he wrote the
chick case of Charles Dexter Ward around
this time which was his first novel um
you know and things like that he started
you know hanging out with Harry Houdini
and writing stuff there wrote the
Dunwich horror that done its horror if
you want to be like that I usually see
Dunwich but I think it's actually done
it
I mean I think that's not your
pronouncing but yeah so he wrote that
kind of stuff and and everything now
like I said him and Sonia had been
living apart for a very long time and
then finally she writes to him and is
like you know look we should just get
divorced because obviously you're not
gonna move here and I have to stay here
for work and stuff so so he now I've
read that some sources that he never
signed the divorce papers even though he
said he did because she moved to Europe
for a little while and farted around and
then she moved out to California and
then she married again and I was like if
that's true that HP said yeah I totally
signed the divorce papers than he did it
that would make her a bigamist mm-hmm
without her knowing yeah
so thanks HP that was nice of you but
like I said I just saw that on the one
source so I don't know but um you know
um most other sources say you know they
eventually got it was an amicable
divorce they didn't like yell at each
other anything like that they just they
were incompatible I mean she was kind of
a woman of the world she wanted to go to
Europe she wanted to go here and there
and he didn't want to go didn't go
anywhere he would just go to your home
the French people oh no he actually did
want to go to go well no I don't know if
he wanted to go to France bogus I'm just
kidding I love France but um he wanted
to go to the UK obviously wanted to see
the hunky motherland like you said but
yeah so he actually do want to go but he
never got to he never left the United
States so you know like I said at this
stage even though he was making some
money from his writing like I said you
know pretty much exclusively getting
published in Weird Tales you know he get
like $100 here $50 there doing some
ghost writing for other authors and
whatnot but it still wasn't all that
much he did have a little bit of the
inheritance from whipple left but by the
time HP was getting towards his death
when he was 46 it was pretty much all
depleted so he was just kind of living
on if they'd had ramen noodles back then
maybe the he just being ramen college
student because that's what that and
it's sad because I mean it's not sad
because like I said he seemed like kind
of an ass like as a person but
I love his writing so much and like he's
been so influential that it just seems
really sad that he never knew I mean he
got published in his lifetime but when
he died no one other than like a few
people that read pulp fiction you knew
who he was like he wasn't a household
name no you know if you if you weren't
in those circles you know to sum him up
he was a sheltered and shy man of his
time he would have been he was strange
for his time he was unusual but he was
an innovator and so in a certain way
because of his personal shortcomings he
was not able to promote his work yeah so
he never reached his full potential in
his lifetime yeah it took a long time
for his work to really be acknowledged
yeah you know and he was long gone by
then yeah so it was oh it was a shame
really and what made him interesting and
innovative also I think limited him you
know it limited his ability to promote
himself what he was yeah and like I said
it's kind of sad because it's kind of a
double-edged sword because because his
neuroses were so profound that he
couldn't benefit and he had kind of a
poor miserable life because of that he
needed one agent but if he had had a
normal life I don't think he would he
wouldn't be right in that with the stuff
that he came up with just like I said
very much the godfather of modern horror
he's the first modern horror writer only
a really weird xenophobic kind of
reclusive kind of guy with a weird
imagination to come up with this kind of
stuff yeah it was subversive in his day
very handsome erst it's can because you
could probably consider it subversive
today yeah you know
but he didn't have a good agent
no had he had an agent and the manager
yeah it would have been I think a
different story even though like I said
you know he had an audience you know the
readers of Weird Tales he had a lot of
other writers that he corresponded with
who were fans of his work who took his
work and ran with it but like I said he
had not he had never been published
outside of the pulps until his death he
died of intestinal cancer when he was 46
years old in 1937 and it was really
shortly after he died you know two of
his friends who had also written you
know using his mythos August Derleth and
Donald Wan dry started Arkham House and
initially they started just to publish
his stuff because so much of his stuff
wasn't published but later on it kind of
became this really good and in fact
Arkham house was kind of it was the
first publishing house to take horror
and fantasy and sci-fi seriously like as
a serious literary form because before
that it had been kind of like cheap-jack
yeah you know other than even stuff like
Dracula and stuff like that back in the
day was kind of seen as like penny
dreadful you know horror was not a
respected genre well he had a lot of
potential was never tapped yeah during
his lifetime
King Kong came out a movie like King
Kong could have been made from
Lovecraft's work yeah good call of
cthulhu could have been a King Kong type
movie in fact in recent times they made
a black-and-white movie that's you can
see it for free on YouTube and it's it's
done like by King Kong I think it's it's
silent though yeah they did call it
Cthulhu like that they also did the
Whisperer in darkness but that's also
black and white looking like a movie
back then but it's a talkie that's a
talk that's the HP Lovecraft
historical so I think so I think that's
a really good example of what could have
been yeah had he had proper management
yeah and proper representation because
this material would have made good would
have been
good in the movies yeah you just needed
it to show it the right way no
screenplay I have to say that
adaptations have his work there have
been a lot of good ones but there been a
lot of shitty ones though yeah I mean I
feel like there's you know the problem I
think with some of his stuff
particularly the Cthulhu Mythos stuff
and like I said that was expanded a lot
like after his death by other writers
Robert E Howard who wrote the cone and
story [ __ ] even the Konya some of the
Conan stories have Cthulhu type themes
in it you know you got manly Wade
Wellman Robert Bloch who were at psycho
you know there were all kind of
disciples and they actually got their
start getting published by Arkham house
to which like I said was you know the
first publishing house that actually
specialized in that kind of stuff um but
I think the problem with adapting a lot
of HP Lovecraft stuff particularly the
early stuff is that so much of the mood
and so much of the story and the fear or
like hinges on you not being able to
describe what you're seeing you're not
supposed to be able to see these things
without going crazy yeah so by showing
them in a movie you're kind of ruining
it yeah so I think like I said I think
John Carpenter when he made the thing
which as I said is very very loved
crafty in I think he did the right thing
by showing the monster a lot but you
don't know exactly what the monster
looks like because it's always taking on
the form of something else so you don't
see its final form you just see it
transforming into other things dogs or
people or what have you so I think that
was a good way to go and carpenter I
think he did you know he did in the
mouth of madness which again was I think
was a good Lovecraft adaptation some of
you know obviously some of the more
direct ones that Stuart Gordon did dagon
reanimate her those are really good but
I don't know I just feel like it's hard
to get right there's a lot of good ones
but there's a lot of [ __ ] ones too and
when I was watching the video earlier
because I was kind of curious about it
you know what ones had come out lately
that were maybe inspired by Lovecraft if
not you know directly based on his
stories what were some good ones I was
watching some of these guys videos where
they were recommended
and you know that the two that I
mentioned earlier in the show that I
kind of want to check out because I
sounded really good but there were some
other recent ones like the void was very
Lovecraftian was then that was very good
you know one called the endless which I
actually just watched a couple nights
ago
I think it's on Netflix or shudder I
can't remember but that's again not a
direct adaptation but it's very much in
that spirit you know what I mean where
it's just kind of like warped reality
type of thing but it's just interesting
and I wish in some ways I wish that he
had lived to have seen that he created
an entire genre of horror that did not
exist before cosmic horror or
Lovecraftian horror as they call it he
did that one guy yeah and he died before
he knew and liked and that documentary
that I saw they were talking to Peter
Straub I think it was and he said you
know when he died he would have been
justified in thinking that he was a
failure because from his point of view
he was he didn't really make any money
he wasn't known he just published a few
stories and anyway we heard tales and
nobody knew who he was other than a few
yeah science fiction and horror fans and
that's that's kind of a shame and that's
you know as much as much as much as I
you know have a thing with his like
weirdness and it's like personal
neuroses and stuff like that he was
probably like I said not a fun dude to
have it parties but that's one thing
that I do wish I wish he lived long
enough to have seen at least some of the
influence that he would later have
because it really seems a shame that he
never got to see that cuz I think he
would have liked that
you know when the bad guy was just weird
yeah yeah like I said I'm not you know
I'm not [ __ ] on him it's like you
know some of the [ __ ] was that was a
product at the time he probably had a
lot of undiagnosed mental illnesses and
maybe some physical illnesses too
obviously he probably had some physical
illnesses because he had [ __ ]
intestinal cancer when he was six that's
shit's not normal but um you know so
some of it was probably beyond you know
wasn't his fault and there wasn't
anything he could do about it
yeah but you know
said that it just it's a shame that he
didn't that he never knew yeah because
that would probably blow his [ __ ]
mind if you do if you invented a time
machine you brought him to like spooky
empire or something like that yeah and
there's like a whole [ __ ] there's a
whole Cthulhu industry there but people
making thousand-dollar statues of
Cthulhu yeah he has inspired an entire
generation of horror artists filmmakers
writers you know everything
painters all kind of [ __ ] it's funny
because I actually this shirt right here
that says I don't know you can't see the
bottom what does it say at the bottom
done much yes but um I gotta actually
got that at spooky Empire when it was
called scream Kon or whatever the [ __ ]
it used to be called um I have this one
and I have the Cthulhu tequila one which
I've probably worn on a few other shows
too but um you know so I wrap it up
there yeah and like I said I think even
though at the time I think he was kind
of considered a pulp writer a hack as
stuff was stuff like that but now that
he's had you know the classy like
Penguin Classics thing of his work and
everything I think now he's kind of
recognized as one of the great modern
American writers so I think that's kind
of good it took a long time for him to
get his due but he finally got it
yeah so good for you HP sauce HP sauce
that's my name for him alright we're
gonna wrap this up cuz this is probably
super long like it usually is so
remember if you like the show like share
subscribe on all your social media if
you'd like to financially support the
show you can go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
and there's a little button in the
sidebar sidebar that says that you can
go donate on paypal if you'd like to do
that also check out our last movie
retrospective which was poltergeist from
1982 and remember our regular episodes
come out every Tuesday and our movie
retrospectives come out every Friday
yeah it's on [ __ ] shoot too we also
have a [ __ ] shoot yeah yeah and we also
have thirteen o'clock matinee three new
movies in theatres that comes out every
Sunday if you're on patreon you actually
get all the shows a day early so that
might be
incentive for you to go check that out
and that will do it for episode 133 we
will see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]